christopher dick most senior police
officer in the police service she
resigned on thursday
given her track record was that the
right thing for her to do
i was um really quite surprised by the
resignation trevor and my my view on
questa is she's led the
the metropolitan police with care
compassion and candor she's uh she's
really generated great loyalty amongst
uh the front line troops and
in effect she's been overtaken by a
series of what i can only describe as
catastrophic events she was walking
wasn't she an incredibly tough tight
rope so
post the uh appalling killing of sarah
everard and the erosion of public trust
she really needed to focus on
rebuilding that trust while at the same
time kind of maintaining the confidence
of her own staff you know the vast
majority of the the men and women
working across the met are getting up
every day to do a great job for members
of the public but i think the kind of
the scale of the event so from sarah
everard through to the photographs of
nicole smallman and bieber henry which
was just a disgrace i think the the last
straw was really the charing cross
incident i can only describe it as an
abomination the comments that we heard
there i've never heard the likes in any
walk of life let alone policing
and although cressida had a plan and
i've looked at the plan and i think it
was a pretty good plan the trouble was
it wasn't moving at pace and that's what
led to the situation we found earlier on
in the week with her finding she had no
option but to resign
so do you think that the mayor in the
end was right to
say he
had no longer had confidence in her
that's got to be a decision for him and
i know i know that's a kind of a get out
of jail free kind of comment but the
issue
the issue that i think that he saw was
that the the reform wasn't happening at
pace the trouble i think that the mayor
and now the home secretary who leads on
the appointment of the met commissioner
the problem that they now have is
whoever the income the incoming
commissioner is they will have a very
very full inbox and they will have
precisely the same problems that crestor
was contending with to deal with and the
problem here trevor is
at the root of this is there is
a real cultural issue in the met that
needs to be unpacked unpicked and dealt
with and we know that that's not going
to happen overnight but that needs to be
at the top of the new commissioner's
inbox i think creston was a very
talented leader there are obviously many
other talented police officers up and
down the country will they do a better
job than cresta well that remains to be
seen but she was really at the forefront
of police leadership
um
one of the things that has been said
about this series of events is that um
the mayor
spoke in his statement this week about
the culture of misogyny racism and
homophobia
some reports say it reminded him of the
bad old days of police when he was
growing up
is that what a commissioner should
really mostly be judged on rather than
whether they are
catching bad people stopping burglaries
stopping night crime on the streets
it's you know it's it's a great question
as as ever
the issue with public trust is is not
that it's a nice thing to have it's
essential because in this country we
police by consent
and when that
trust arose the whole legitimacy
of policing erodes as well whether
that's in terms of people reporting to
the police whether that's in terms of
people from
communities that aren't properly
represented within policing coming
forward and joining the police it is so
much at the heart of all that the police
do that it is right to focus on trust
but you know the other part of your
question is should the met commissioner
be focusing on the day job too yeah
absolutely i mean there's been a series
of reports over the last week or so
about the extent to which the police are
actually serving the public well across
the country you know i find it pretty
dismal that only five percent of
burglaries of burglars are brought to
justice one percent of rapes end in
conviction
i lead on violence against women and
girls or did in my former role and i was
astonished that three quarters of
domestic abuse related crime reported to
the police was being closed down early
uh before uh before the offender is
brought to justice on the grounds of
evidential difficulties there's 1.6
million crimes of domestic abuse
a year trevor you do do the math how how
many
how many of our victims are being uh
left in that position where they've
reported to the police but actually
they've not seen an outcome which they
think is just unfair so quite right in
terms of your question we've got to look
at both sides of this do the day job
well please use their powers well keep
keep keep the londoners safe but also
absolutely rebuilding trust is central
to all of this
well you've spoken um eloquently about
the day job and uh the the data you've
just given some of it uh suggests that
actually things are getting even worse
and that
as you've quoted the figures on rape
which seem extraordinarily low on knife
crime um
the number the proportion of offenders
given the immediate custodial sentences
decreased to 31 percent uh but from 2020
to 2021.
what is going wrong
i think there's a whole range of um
factors the police are really busy
there is no denying that and certainly
when i was her majesty's inspector of
constabulary we saw a massive increase
in crime going on to the books not
necessarily because there was
more crime but the police were getting a
whole lot better at reporting it
i think in some forces there's been a
tendency with all of this busyness
um to look for easy routes to close
crimes down rather than to have to
investigate them rapidly and i'm always
quite depressed when i hear about crimes
going into what's called a a crime
resolution desk which is where someone
has a quick look at the crime works out
if there's any leads to follow was there
any cctv was there any witnesses and
makes a really rapid decision
then not to investigate further the
police are there to do
very basic things in policing turn up
quick
listen to the victim and take what they
say at face value and and believe them
and do a proper investigation you know
do house to house inquiries look for
cctv not push it all back onto the
victim to do all that themselves and if
the police aren't turning up rapidly you
know that golden hour it's a bit of an
old cliche but that golden hour of
actually being able to gather that
evidence to build a case to bring the
offender to justice you know to some
extent again a cliche but back to some
of the basics in policing
across england wales i think
you um let's
find if i may just come back to this
point of trust that uh you spoke about
um
part of it is getting the day job done
but part of it presumably is also
behaving properly half of the police
employees who committed growth
misconduct in the last three years were
not dismissed
of 118 cases where standards breach was
proven by disciplinary panels
only 55 led to the sack according to an
analysis of figures by the independent
office for police conduct and this is
not just a met this is across
the board
this is just not good enough is it
no it's not the public won't understand
it i don't understand it
it makes no sense you know i think the
whole
complexity of police regulations around
discipline and misconduct needs a
complete overhaul i hope the various
reviews that are ongoing uh will
completely look at this because if
people transgress in this position of
power and trust and this is what this is
in policing then they do need to be
brought to book and i don't think the
public i don't know the details behind
sharon cross but i think it's hard for
the public to fathom um that two of
those officers who were at the very
least bystanders in that abomination of
that discussion on what's that have now
been have now been promoted what sort of
message is that sending out across the
organization so yeah we definitely need
to have a look at misconduct we also
trevor need to look at the type of
person that we want to see within
policing what are their traits what's
their ambitions why are they joining
policing in the first place and when
they have joined what what are the
police doing to make sure if there are
rotten
apples that the counter corruption
measures in place are sufficient to be
able to root them out